Let's go through a few examples. A teacher with a jazz appreciation class says
that his students really like the jazz music that he's playing. And he
concludes that the class is causing the students to enjoy jazz music. Another
situation, researches note that drug use is correlated with delinquency. They
conclude drug use causes delinquency and if we reduce drug use, we can also
decrease delinquency. What's wrong with the logic in each of these situations.
In the case of the jazz music, perhaps students really liked jazz before and
that's why they took the Jazz Appreciation class. Rather than the jazz
appreciation class causing them to like jazz. For the second situation, it's
possible that people were delinquent and that's why they started using drugs.
In both of these situations, there's ambiguous temporal precedence. We don't
know which variable occurred first, if it was the class or the appreciation for
jazz or if there was drug use and then delinquency. Those are just two examples
where we can't infer causality. Here's another one and one that's near and dear
to my heart as an educator. We found a correlation between SAT scores and
students grades in college. Can we include them that increasing students SAT
scores will also increase their grades in college? Or what about this one, some
people who commit violent acts played violent video games before committing
these acts. Therefore these video games caused violence. What are the flaws in
the logic here, for these two situations? This situation is called a third
variable problem. It's not necessarily true that high SAT scores resulted in
high grades in college. It could be that motivation, effort, intelligence
etcetera was a third variable that influenced both SAT scores And college
grades. And this situation's called a post hoc fallacy. Just because a person
played violent video games before committing a violent act this doesn't mean
that the violent video games caused the violent acts. It could be that people
who want to commit violent crimes also want to play violent video games. There
is actually a lot of research on this that I'm unaware of. But certainly a
simple correlation wouldn't be enough to determine this. Here is the punch
line. Get it. Just remember, correlation is super-useful but it does not imply
causation.